we've been so cautious keeping quiet
only moving at night but sometimes
despite all your best efforts you just
get unlucky we made our way through what
we thought was an abandoned street
littered with broken down cars when
those things had slithered out and
ambushed us kasparov who was always the
most trigger-happy of us panicked and
opened fire with his scavenged
submachine gun on the largest of the
creatures big mistake it didn't slow the
monster down and only seemed to attract
more it'd be blob city before sunrise
now but poor kaspar wouldn't make it
that long fleshy tendrils wrapped around
his limbs and pulled him into the
terrible mass of one of the creatures it
started reshaping around him enveloping
him as he screamed until the tide of
flesh coursing down his throat silenced
him the whole time the monster just kept
jibbering madness in a warped voice
become one yes
let ourselves spawn and our minds
coagulate in the glorious shimmering
light
we will all be one in daylight pretty
flower
yes
yes
yes
and then there were four me ellen darcy
and jones there had been more of us once
but in this war of attrition we always
seemed to be the ones who had to lose
and if we didn't get away from these
monsters quickly then there wouldn't be
any of us left soon enough we ran
ducking and weaving around the cars as
the blobs got closer there were so many
of them all howling and ranting zealots
for the only cause their melted excuses
for minds could understand anymore
occasionally we fired back hoping to
slow them down a little but it never
worked the guns of anything were a
psychological support mechanism and
something to scare off other survivors
who were even more desperate than us
when it came to the blobs especially the
big ones the only things you could do
were run and hope and hopes in short
supply these days no matter how fast we
ran the blobs kept catching up they
didn't seem to get tired knowing we
couldn't outrun them we ran up to one of
the abandoned cars and crouched behind
them breathing raggedly this whole
stupid mission in hopes of eventually
reaching safety a good night's sleep
behind solid walls and some people who
actually know what the hell is going on
i drew my sidearm out of my pocket even
if i didn't make it out of here i
wouldn't turn into one of those monsters
pulling back the hammer i muttered a
quiet prayer but there's a god out there
he had a hell of a lot to answer for
right now i looked to ellen darcy and
jones and they all had the same idea it
was a pleasure to know them all after
everything that had happened we heard
the blobs getting closer their lunatic
whispers growing in volume and intensity
as they always did before they claimed
one of us i breathed in a sigh ready to
accept my fate knowing what i needed to
do it all seemed to be over until he
appeared i looked up and spotted a
strange man approaching he was dressed
in old-fashioned hessian toga his hair
and beard frosty white i couldn't
identify his age or race but those
factors seem secondary to the fact his
eyes were glowing brilliant white as if
exuding pure energy he raised a hand the
same glowing aura of pure white energy
emanating off of it i'd seen so many
things that terrified me in the past six
months but this this was the first time
i'd experienced something i could call
awe he walked towards us with a
stillness and confidence instead you
look like you could use a hand
where were you when day broke whoever's
left they remember i was in a
supermarket with my wife and two kids
just another normal day i was worrying
about bills taxes and whatever we were
going to have for dinner that night if
the devil exists i'd sell my soul to
that nasty red creep to get those
worries back lucky for us we were in the
back half of the store but entirely by
artificial light the people checking out
their groceries down front right in the
front of the building's huge glass
facade they were the first to go down
all these terrible drowned screams first
the exact kind of shrieks you'd expect
from somebody starting to melt than the
gurgling like a backed up drain as their
mouth and throat melted around the sound
choking it those were the first few
minutes of hell on earth i've never been
the smartest man i was a roofer back
when things made sense never went to
college never been much for reading but
i had intuition and i credit that with
surviving this long my dad was in the
service two tours in nam he always told
me when i was a kid the guys who didn't
make it back they panicked because
that's what the enemy wants you to do
they hope when everything hits the fan
you'll break formation forget the plan
and i'll start scurrying in different
directions like rats just hoping you'll
be the one who finds a crack and gets
out that's when they get you when you
panic you're giving up the birthright of
reason from letting the animal take over
and animals some are easier to kill when
the sun went bad that day plenty of
people in that store started running
they didn't know what they were running
from or where they were running to they
just wanted to put some distance between
themselves and the screaming every man
for himself i'd love to tell you all
those people are dead now but in
actuality they were in for a far worse
fate they ran out of the safety and
cover of the store putting themselves at
the mercy of the light even as they
melted they kept running they were blobs
slithering away not even knowing that
the thing they were running from had
already gotten them it all happened so
fast but i can remember every single
detail you can judge me if you like i
don't care anymore if i could have
spoken reason to those terrified people
that day hand on my heart i would have
but one of man's greatest design flaws
is that god made fear the master of
reason nothing i could have said that
day would have changed anything the only
ones i could hope to save were my family
so that's exactly what i did we grabbed
what we could stayed away from windows
made our way to the nearest supply
closet we were in there for hours we
didn't come out until things were
actually quiet which coincidentally
happened to be night when we stepped
outside the store we saw the carnage
that must have unfolded over the past
few hours windows smashed cars driven
into storefronts and abandoned
slithering blobs of former people on the
ground in the space of a few hours the
world had truly and irrevocably changed
no matter what happened even if we
survived we knew there would never be a
normal as we'd know it before ever again
the same message was playing on every tv
radio and computer a logo i didn't quite
recognize along with an overlay that
read an important message from the scp
foundation it explained in an eternally
looping robotic voice that they were
superseding the control of all world
governments to protect humanity from
this new and terrifying threat in short
the sun had turned against us in some
scenarios survival is a curse in those
early days and weeks you wouldn't
believe the number of times i started to
envy the dead people who'd been wiped
off the mortal coil by disease and car
crashes and random acts of violence in
the days before day broke they had no
idea how good they had it little by
little in this terrible new world death
became a kind of luxury because melting
under the fiery gaze of the sun that
wasn't death not even close they seemed
harmless at first tragic pitiful really
the voices on the tv even told us that
to avoid starvation we could eat small
parts of the melted but over time the
situation evolved i don't know when it
started or why but the blobs that had
once been people started coagulating
they joined up started turning into
bigger creatures all with one mind
always screaming and talking madness in
a collage of stolen voices these
monsters existed for one purpose and one
purpose only finding the people who were
still normal and dragging them out into
the light to join them they roamed the
world during the night hunting seeking
and given night was the only time we
could ever safely move this created
problems for all of us we lost so many
to those terrible monsters including my
wife and both my kids see what i mean
about survival sometimes being a curse
especially when you've got people to
miss i wish they were dead all three of
them but i still hear them their voices
added to the chorus of a house-sized
flesh monster but i lived on if you can
call this living i met with others like
kaspar ellen darcy and jones all of them
had lost people you hadn't lived this
long if you hadn't lost people we did
all we could to keep surviving against
the odds we spent our days in basements
and abandoned stores in our nights
dodging the flesh creatures and foraging
for food we eked out each day taking
every breath as it came we didn't help
for anything until one day we heard that
the people at the scp foundation might
know how to reverse all this they needed
all the people and help they could get
at one of their bases around 20 miles
from us it'd only be a couple nights
walk to get there we figured so why not
help out the cause safety and numbers
after all and truth be told we miss
people after days of hiding and nights
of traveling we were ambushed but you
already know about that part we lost
kasparov to one of those monsters and
got cornered behind an abandoned car
however as the blobs got closer and
closer that mysterious stranger with the
glowing eyes appeared he didn't walk
like the rest of us he was bold
confident his back straight as a dancers
like he feared nothing like nothing here
could hurt him suddenly i felt a
rumbling behind me the car was rattling
i feared for a second that the blobs
were crawling over it to get us but when
i turned i saw the opposite was
happening the car was rising off of the
ground free floating myself and the
other survivors stared in astonishment
as the stranger simply flicked his wrist
the floating car was thrown with
tremendous force at the largest of the
advancing blobs it hit the beast so hard
that the top of it simply splattered off
freezing what was left in place even the
other blobs paused seemingly astonished
we all turned to the stranger still
standing firm stand behind me if you
wish to live
he said there was something both
passionate and commanding about his
voice it was impossible to hear him and
not heed his words all of us stood up
and ran behind the stranger as he lifted
both hands debris climbed into the air
cars rocks broken glass the blobs were
beginning to coagulate again but this
time the stranger wasn't going to let
them get the upper hand again with a
slight nod everything he'd raised flew
at the blobs with the force of a machine
gun they were decimated the bigger ones
cut apart the smaller one fleeing to
avoid the onslaught after months of
running from these monsters i don't
think any sight could have been more
satisfying when the creatures were gone
the stranger just gave a quiet sigh he
turned to us and asked if we were okay
the answer was essentially about as much
as we can be he told us that we'd be
safe as long as we stuck with him and
after that display we had every reason
we had every reason to believe him we
followed the stranger down the long dark
road he always walked in the middle
fearless making no attempt to hide when
we asked him his name he told us that he
goes by many names but for the sake of
simplicity we could call him matthew we
thanked matthew for saving us and he
gave a sad sort of smile and told us
that he only wished he could have done
more there was something so strange
about matthew even beyond the fact he
apparently had superpowers i'd never met
the man before and i'd be willing to bet
my right hand on that and yet it felt
like i'd known him my entire life he was
so different and yet so incredibly
familiar we told him we were on our way
to a nearby scp foundation facility
where we were told we'd find safe haven
we asked him if he knew where to find it
matthew told us that in fact he'd lived
there in that very site for decades a
visitor just dropping in he'd had a very
stressful job before and felt like
taking a sabbatical while things ran
themselves for once evidently my help
was more necessary than i imagined
he said occasionally as we walked we'd
see blobs watching us from crevices and
dark alleys on the side of the road they
seemed to watch but for some reason
didn't approach it was the most
remarkable thing don't worry
he told us i'm putting up invisible
shoes
none of them can approach us as long as
i maintain my focus
of course we'd all heard stories of
remarkable and terrifying things
wandering the wasteland we used to call
planet earth you couldn't run into other
survivors and groups without hearing
whispers about the things lurking out
there some had told of a giant monstrous
reptile that had destroyed an entire
survivor settlement in a mall outside of
nevada others told that one of those scp
sites was haunted people spoke about a
ghostly man who looked like a rotten
corpse who could walk through walls and
drag people to hell but the things
matthew was capable of seemed to be on a
whole other level i asked him what he
was and he told me just a humble
craftsman myself
i enjoy creating though admittedly my
creations seem to have gotten away from
me these days
his evasion was less funny than he
seemed to think it was i pressed on
asking him what exactly he was capable
of he shrugged and answered that he
could do almost anything if he really
put his mind to it i asked so
ultimate power this gave him a chuckle
he shook his head and said let me tell
you a story
a man comes upon a maze cut into a
cornfield and decides he wants to dry
his luck
he spends hours getting to the center of
the maze and there he finds the devil
waiting for him the devil says
welcome to my domain your soul is now
forfeit unless you can complete my
challenge and win it back
of course the men agreed
the devil said
i can see everything do everything and
be everything
i know every inch of the universe and
can produce anything from thin air
if you want to keep your soul
name one thing i can't do
curious i asked what did the man say
matthew smiled and said good luck
and for the first time in those long
dark months i actually laughed and it
was such a stupid corny dad joke it's a
strange world we live in boy news
matthew continued there is no ultimate
power
some things are denied even to god
especially when he chooses to walk as a
man on the earth he created
we kept walking for hours matthew
assured us that we would get there in
time as the rest of us got even more
anxious about the thought of the rising
sun he said he'd seen so many sunrises
now that he could time them to the
second in the meantime we should enjoy
getting to stretch our legs a little
even now the city could be beautiful at
night when he led us all the way to what
seemed like an abandoned chemical plant
i could feel my heart sink all this time
all this work to find more people to
find safety only to see that this place
was abandoned too matthew smiled and
said that's just what they want you to
think
he snapped his fingers and the ground
around us began to rumble the concrete
shifted seamlessly and an entrance
opened up below heavy bulkheads shifted
revealing a sleek chrome hallway down
into the ground we were astonished
matthew gestured down into the hall as
we descended matthew followed us the
entrance closing behind him i'm just
warning you
he said this may come as a bit of a
shock
we ventured deeper passing through
different automated security checkpoints
as cameras gazed down from above
eventually we found ourselves in what
seemed to be a central chamber it was a
hive of activity people in normal
civilian clothes guards and tactical
gear scientists and lab coats tears
filled my eyes it was the most people
i'd seen in one place in months the man
in the lab coat wearing an extravagant
medallion approached he was making notes
on a clipboard another batch of
survivors good work 343 the man said
matthew smiled and nodded no problem
jack
always happy to help
the man with the medallion jack
presumably turned to me i imagine you've
come a long way he said i nodded
you have no idea now go check out
scp-001 when day breaks and your
questions for god answered for more
information on the anomalies featured in
today's tale